what she wrote yesterday I utterly
condemn and I said we would tear out
anti-termitism by its roots I meant it
and that's why we acted so swiftly
yesterday I think it's a mark of how far
the labor party has changed that we
acted so swiftly and that we take it so
seriously but I condemn what she said
but I'm specifically saying is it
anti-semitic what she wrote yesterday in
your view I condemn what she said but
there's obviously an investigation
there's an investigation going on now
but look I don't think anybody can doubt
the change in the labor party when you
see that swifter action and our absolute
commitment to zero tolerance I mean the
editor of the Jewish Chronicle says that
it takes a lot to surprise me when it
comes to anti-Semitism but for sheer
ignorant malice it's hard to think of a
worse example than Mrs Abbott's word
yesterday
question you've seen the words you've
read them in your view is what Diana
Abbott wrote yesterday anti-semitic or
not in my view what she said was uh to
be condemned it was anti-semitic it's
absolutely right that we acted as
swiftly as we did that's the change that
you've seen in the labor party but do I
condemn what she said I absolutely
condemn what she said do I want to show
the labor party takes this seriously and
acts very quickly yes I do and that's
why we acted as swiftly as we did
yesterday so if you say you've got a
zero tolerant approach to all of this
and you've just said it is anti-Semitic
surely she cannot stand as a labor
candidate at the next election well as
you know there's an investigation going
on at the moment what reason there's an
investigation going on at the moment
that's the right thing the whip has been
suspended that was done very very
swiftly and I have condemned what she
said along with many other people well
what's the purpose of the investigation
I mean you've read a word you've judged
it as anti-semitic what's this
investigation to find out she's
apologized surely she cannot stand as a
lady a candidate if you've got a genuine
Zero Tolerance approach I think
everybody understands that there has to
be an investigation in every case and
nobody has said to me there shouldn't be
an investigation what they want to see
as a labor party that demonstrates by
its actions that it's changed that it
does have zero tolerance and that's why
we acted as quickly as we did yesterday
okay just very finely on this how
disappointed are you that yet again here
we are today talking about anti-Semitism
racism within the labor party of course
I'm disappointed we should be talking
about the cost of living today there are
many people today who can't afford the
basic food they need or their energy
bills that's what we should be talking
about so of course I'm disappointed that
we're talking about anti-Semitism let's
move on let's talk about another serious
situation today in Sudan do you think
the government's doing enough to
evacuate British citizens there
first let me acknowledge it's a really
difficult and fast-moving situation in
Sudan and let me also pay tribute to our
troops and the work they've done to
bring our diplomats out again in very
very difficult circumstances there is a
huge concern about British residents who
are there and need to be
helped to get out of Sudan I do urge the
government to do everything that they
can to help those remaining in Sudan
we've heard some of their voices in the
last 24 hours but look I do acknowledge
it's a really difficult situation and we
will support the government in any
action they are able to take let's talk
about the cost of living crisis I read
your press release this morning that
talked about coverts and talked about uh
the pen uh so the war in Ukraine have an
effect on inflation you say that's not
unique to the UK why would you talk
about brexit which is are you unique to
the UK and may well be leading to
Britain's economic troubles well as you
will have seen in the press release we
put out today we did talk about brexit
we said look there's a cost of living
crisis it's worse in this country than
other countries and the government needs
to account for that 40 percent on
essential items is the rate of inflation
that's impossible for many many families
in order to deal with that we need to
get to grips with the energy crisis have
a real plan a labor plan for energy to
bring those bills down but also we need
a better relationship with the EU to get
a better brexit deal and the sooner that
we're able to bring about the change
that we need in this country then the
better for the millions of families who
today will be watching this and knowing
that they're really really struggling to
make ends meet just two final quick
questions at one on the S P leader who
the prime minister's meeting later on
today are you Keen to meet at the new
SMP leader do you Scotland first
Minister well
the leader it's very important that we
do meet political leaders I have to say
that the SNP is I think finally being
held to account for its awful record in
government
um and they're collapsing in on
themselves so
um I'll be interested to know how the
meeting with the Prime Minister goes
later on today but at a basic level of
course we should speak to all political
leaders and so finally Len Goodman's
died this morning it's a lot of the
National Treasure yeah real sadness I
think across uh the country Mr strictly
in many respects and you know they're in
our living rooms for a very very long
time on a Saturday night I think across
the country there'll be a genuine and
heartfeltness sadness at this turn of
events